okay so Luanne sium is the last of the
five f actinide series and there is
truly not a lot to say about his have
got absolutely no use whatsoever
Lorenzen was named after yo lawrence who
was an american physicist in berkeley
california and he was probably one of
the first people who really did science
on a huge scale building enormous
machines huge laboratories and he set up
in the early 1930s he set up
laboratories with large mass
spectrometers cyclotrons for separating
materials and of different masks and he
during the Second World War he was one
of the key figures in the Manhattan
Project for building the nuclear first
nuclear bombs and in fact my wife's
father John Keane as a undergraduate was
sent from Birmingham University to
Berkeley to work with you Lawrence as
part of his work war service working on
the mass spectrometer working on the
problems of separating the isotopes of
uranium and it's also quite interesting
that lawrencium for a lot of people is
the end of the periodic table and if you
look at my time here you can see that if
I point here thereafter lawrencium this
is an old tie that there's a blank the
element stopped there but by the time I
bought my next tie they'd filled in
these blanks and so now I've got another
tie which you may have seen on some of
the other frames where they're no blank
frames in the on the tie at all